one of the things that the government
wants to do
is ubi universal basic income
and many people through the last
12 15 18 months thought that these
stimulus payments
was a testing ground you know what let's
give 1200 bucks
let's give 600 let's give 1400
checks all in all if you were in the top
bracket
for stimulus payments you basically got
3 200 in three separate installments
over the last
12 15 months now
the problem with this from people who
are
critics of universal basic income
is that if you guarantee someone
that you are going to give them free
money
you do not have to have a job you do not
have to work you do not have to do
anything productive you simply can get a
check from the government
every single month they're not
incentivized to go get a job
duh right if you don't incentivize
people to go to work
then they're not going to go to work
like it's not hard to figure that out
incentives drive the world now what
we've seen
is during the period where there were
stimulus checks
where there was boosters for
unemployment and there was generally
increased government support whether
that was through eviction moratoriums
student loan uh lack of payments
etc people did not want to go to work
and so what ended up happening was
companies had to keep increasing the
amount of pay so you could argue that
the
outcome of companies paying employees
more ended up being good
but what companies then did was they
turned around and they took the higher
cost of labor
the higher cost of the actual materials
for their products and services
and they passed it on to the customer
and they increased prices
what ended up occurring is well the
government handed out
free money in the to the tune of 3 200
per person in some cases those people
are worse off today than they were
before
their hourly job actually pays them less
in purchasing power terms than it did
before
the cost of living based on the official
cpi numbers which we know to be
inaccurate
increase the cost of living by 5.4
percent it is not how this has happened
there is a new bill that is proposed in
congress
that would send monthly payments or the
new terminology
guaranteed income of up to twelve
hundred dollars for adults and six
hundred dollars for children
following a pilot program across the
united states as proposed on friday
it's known as the sending unconditional
payments to people overcoming resistance
to triumph which is a crazy name
called the support act and the plan is
quote designed to build a 21st century
economy that is reflective of
americans everyday needs they definitely
went back and wrote that name after
thinking of the acronym support right
of course by the way
i also pride myself on being able to
take complex
ideas and turn them into simplistic
language
the sending unconditional payments to
people overcoming resistances to triumph
can be translated to socialism
that's what this is it is people
depending on their government to give
them free money
for nothing and when you turn a
capitalistic
upstart hungry innovative economic
prosperity driven
country into a socialistic society
where people are dependent on the
government we do not have a single
example
anywhere in the world where that has
proven to be a sustainable strategy
and so the idea here of this new bill is
that it would begin with a 2.5 billion
dollar
grant that would be used in pilot
programs across the us
to be studied from 2023 to 2027.
why 2.5 billion nobody knows why do we
have to wait till 2023 to start
nobody knows why would we only study it
for four years
nobody knows but after reviewing the
findings and best practices
the government could then implement the
program
in 2028. don't worry folks hold on the
government's coming to save you in seven
years
this would establish an office of
guaranteed income programs and the
treasury department would oversee the
payments
there have been dozens of pilot programs
that have been approved
in various places already
but critics of the program say it would
disincentivize work
is there any possibility that the united
states
moves to a universal basic income model
well i wouldn't put it out of the
question depending on who's in
government
but we already saw those same uh effects
that you just mentioned the downside
of disincentivizing people to work we
literally just saw it play out with
unemployment benefits
when you raise that rate of unemployment
benefits to higher than people receiving
at their current job
it disincentivizes them to go back to
work why would you go back to work if
you're making more money from the
government than you were making
previously
right so just uh from an incentive
standpoint it doesn't make much sense
and then you just start you start
thinking about people thinking that the
the government is going to come save
them right
how you mentioned and that's just not
how the united states was built in the
economic power that we are
you have to incentivize people to go to
work to innovate to create jobs
and expand their businesses and
universal basic income does not do that
here within the united states
one of the pieces of this that uh is
underrated in my opinion
is this is going to happen we absolutely
are going to get universal basic income
in this country
i don't like it i don't think we should
do it but we're gonna get there
why because you know what the greatest
political
campaign in the world is to people
who constantly feel like they can't get
ahead don't worry
i just give you free money yeah the
people who are
shepherding and encouraging and
advocating for this type of program
are the exact same people who are going
to go to those that are in the most dire
need
financially and that's their pitch i'll
give you free money
it's vote for me you know what is
equivalent to
remember in high school or middle school
when there was the student body
president
vote and they walked around and they
gave candy to everyone and it was a
popularity contest
that's what this is because they don't
know the other impact of it they don't
understand what it does to them right
when you look at it from an inflation
standpoint and giving people free money
not only from an incentive perspective
of going to get a job but from what it
actually does to the monetary policy in
the country right and and it ruins
basically there uh it widens in a
quality gap it does all these things
that they don't necessarily think about
they're really just thinking about hey
i'm getting free money why wouldn't i
take that
going back to how i started off the show
of i don't
adhere to any political party or any one
issue or anything
i actually think it's a good thing in
the united states
that we have some forms of help for
people
who need some portion of help right
so unemployment as an example if you
have a family
you get laid off from your job you have
no other option
it's a good idea that the government can
help you
for a period of time we're the greatest
country in the world we literally
are the greatest country in the world we
are more powerful than any country
that's ever come before us
we should be able to help people but 78
of americans live paycheck to paycheck
not
and so instead of those types of
programs what we are now talking about
is literally having a persistent program
it doesn't matter what happens
you simply will get your check and what
i think is the most dangerous part about
this
is that the government is essentially
bribing the people
you're giving people 1200 every month
to shut up own nothing and be happy
that's it that is what they're doing and
we see
45 of americans hold no investable
assets
it's crazy and those 45 of americans are
worse off today than they were last year
because
of the devaluation of the currency and
so where are we gonna get
billions and billions if not tens of
billions hundreds of billions of dollars
right
what would it be how many u.s adults are
there times twelve hundred dollars
see see what that math is google how
many u.s
adults we have and then what would it be
if we gave each one of them twelve
hundred dollars
we had ken langone a multi-billionaire
on television last week or two weeks ago
saying to elizabeth warren why are you
sending me
social security a multi-billionaire
is receiving social security checks
it's bonkers to me that these programs
are set up the way that they're set up
and if we continue to simply give
free money you will not only hurt the
people you're giving the money to
you will not only hurt the people who
don't receive any of the money but you
also will go further
and further and further into a federal
debt situation that cannot be
corrected 250.8 billion 250
billion dollars per year 1200
per month times 210 million 18 adults 18
and over
and then children could get 600. so over
250 billion dollars a year this program
would cost
and we can't figure out
where to pay for anything remember the
ted cruz quote
literally we're talking about
legislating things we don't understand
with money we don't have to pay for
things we can't afford exact same thing
here
and so what i think is probably the
craziest part of this entire
idea is that we just talked about how
the free market
actually was able to increase wages
faster than the government has been able
to increase the federal minimum wage
my guess is if the united states
government and the politicians
looked at this and said we cannot use
legislation as the tool in our toolbox
to affect
change instead we are here as servants
of the entrepreneurs the small business
owners
and the citizens of our districts our
states
and our country and we're gonna do
everything we possibly can do to empower
them to solve their problems
and then get the hell out of the way we
would already be in a better position
there would be much less poverty in this
country
people would be a better financial
position and it would start
because we would take the 45 of
americans who hold no investable assets
and we would teach them financial
education
you can't tell me that a country that is
thinking about
mandating universal basic income but
refuses to mandate personal income in
every single school in the country
has its priorities right because the old
adage of
you can fish for someone but you're
better off teaching them how to fish
is true here as well how do you solve
the problem by simply handing somebody
money instead of teaching them how
to thrive on their own well and the
other thing too is the 250 billion
dollars that's
your quoting is per year some of them
want to give 1200 per month
and that's three trillion dollars a year
wait the 250 billion was only
a one-time payment of 1200 yeah so if
you look at it on a promotion 200
million multiply that by 12 million
people
yeah multiply that by 12 and it's three
trillion dollars a year
if you gave every u.s american adult
1200
a month which is what they're planning
on all the money we got but let's be
clear like that would be more than a 10
increase to the federal deficit
as where it stands today every year
three trillion dollars
a year to hand money
and pay people so they don't have to
work
the old ideals of hard work
etc are not dead in this country we
spend
episode after episode after episode here
talking about
people who are immigrants people who
come from nothing people who literally
are able to take a skill that they
developed and build a life of financial
security and wealth
80 percent of millionaires in the united
states inherited zero dollars
33 percent of millionaires in the united
states never made more than a hundred
thousand dollars in any given year
anyone can do it in this country but
what we have to do is we have to get
back to teaching
people financial education we have to
get back
to creating the aspirational nature
of come to america and you can do it too
because when we go from a
entrepreneurship driven a capitalistic
society
where you get value if you create value
and we turn to a government that has
zero clue what they're doing
as we've seen over the last couple of
days with the infrastructure bill
the us government is not likely to
manage this correctly
and the us government is in more debt
than they've ever been
yet they continue to collect more tax
revenue than they've ever collected
we don't have a revenue problem we've
got a spending problem and if you
understand business even at the most
simplistic form
if you keep increasing your revenue but
you keep going further and further
in debt you should stop spending
you should actually run a budget that is
balanced
and one of the best things you can do as
a country is serve as an example for
the people of which you represent
because my guess is if you had 3.5
trillion dollars which by the way is the
new bill that today the democratic party
put forward that is supposed to address
poverty
and climate but my guess
is that less than 20 of it will actually
go to any of those causes
you would be better off taking that
money
handing it directly to people teaching
them
how financial education works and
telling them we will never give you
another dollar
here is it getting you back to the
starting line
here is what you need to know go forth
and be prosperous hey guys thanks so
much for watching that clip of the best
business show
make sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account we can get after it